uh we'll we'll take uh House Bill 130
first
all right so 130 has an amendment
um that uh even though the bill says
we're going to repeal this uh commission
altogether uh this amendment is to
address the problem that gel Carr uh
feels that exists in the current statute
and that is the funding mechanism and
the penalties
um are uh are inappropriate for a
commission and so this amendment uh
basically addresses just that issue it
doesn't it doesn't repeal it it doesn't
change anything other than its funding
mechanism
um I I guess the one thing that did come
up and I just want to make it clear to
everyone uh this bill is way past going
to a second committee so any action we
take uh if this if it does pass the
house and I'm hoping we'll all agree on
this and get another consent calendar
that uh it will then go over to the
Senate and and the Senate Commerce
Committee which Donna Susie sits on who
is the sponsor of the original
commission that uh that she can work on
it and fix it and if if she wants to do
something different different funding
mechanism obviously that's open for
discussion but at least this addresses
the fact that the governor has an
in-house Bill one but he doesn't have it
there's nothing in House Bill 2 to have
a funding mechanism so one way or the
other this language has to be approved
if we hope any money is going to fall go
to that commission this year
with that I'll take questions from the
committee
yes
thank you I just want to make clear that
the the um dalcar I don't know how to
pronounce it did not say that this was
unconstitutional they said they had no
Authority
um they said it should be looked at
further
um though they had they did have say
that they had questions but they did not
say that it couldn't they expect thought
it should move forward and have some
more work done on it but they they were
recommending legislative action
and where the legislative policy
committee to do that
just question this doesn't uh in any way
negate the last Amendment does it we
still have that last Amendment hanging
out there on 130 on 1 30 a.m what's the
last time the whole funding thing
uh that this this amendment's been
around for a while hasn't it uh yeah
yeah I'm not sure
the original 130 was to repeal the whole
law no no then there was an amendment uh
seven uh 748
I can't tell that I don't have a name on
it
no you're talking okay so this would
negate any other Amendment this would be
the only amendment
oh well then I want to know what
happened this is 7 48 page
are you looking at 748h
yes yes that's what we're discussing
then what's
okay
you're looking at the original bill
which was the repeal everything this is
how short it was
yeah yeah repeal could be very short
no problem
did she so she's looking at my Amendment
yeah
uh sure
should we go back to looking at
representative Merchants Amendment
which is what the board would like to do
if we don't retain
uh
uh just did he have an amendment on this
uh yeah do you have anybody in their
file have another amendment
I think he just came in and told us to
kill the bill because he didn't want to
get rid of I mean I remember the hearing
was mostly about not getting rid of the
commission
that's what I remember
okay all right
okay so who's on the insurance committee
do you have anything you can shed light
on here
and don't say no
not on the the subcommittee so I know
but you can still you can still talk so
actually let me let me rephrase my
conversation okay uh I can see how this
is potentially a partisan issue in terms
of this bill and so therefore
um what I would guess what I'm looking
for is you know if the Democrats were
unified to say they're opposed to doing
anything and just to retain it then that
would be a 10-10 vote in this committee
and that would force it to be retained
so I was saying I was making a case for
because you all know I love to retain
bills
you know I like to keep keep bills in
committee but that I thought that given
what happened with gel Carter and I was
more than willing to retain it but given
what happened in gel car I thought it
was worthwhile to go forward with this
so that least we have addressed the
legislative issue and then let the
Senate decide what they want to do with
it
from the from the policy point of view
of course I would like to keep the the
commission from the the state
constitutional point of view
I don't know and uh you don't hear me
say I don't know that often but I don't
I don't know uh but from the policy
point of view of course I would like to
keep the commission
Cara do you have any questions
and I want to know your opinion
kind of want to know your opinion you're
talking to me yeah oh okay
um
I would like us to retain it um that is
what the board would like us to do they
think it's the best option
um their second choice I guess there
wasn't uh there was confusion I guess
they thought Gary Merchant had us as an
amendment and their third choice would
be
um they don't think that the general
fund is going to be um the way to go so
their first choice is to retain and I
frankly would like to to take their lead
on that and go with that and um if
people you know are confused we can take
five minutes as a caucus to talk but I'd
like to see us retain
so beautiful
so who said you agreed you think it you
would rather just do you realize it
means the commission won't theoretically
might not do anything for a year
so do you want us to support the
amendment yes
the bill States repealing the drug
affordability yeah that we it would
change the title if we were to pass this
amendment that would change that a title
okay
ought to pass
ought to pass as amended then we're not
repealing the repealing the drug the
repeal language will disappear
forever ever that's my commitment to you
okay okay my commitment to you personal
commitment okay as much as I'm not very
excited about this this affordability
board that I would I by passing this
amendment I am saying to you is that
that any conversation about repealing it
will not be in this committee
this committee will not talk about
repealing it it will be gone that's not
the issue to us the issue to us was we
never got to see it when it originally
got passed
okay because it was in the it was in the
budget and it was it came over from the
Senate side so it never really uh it
never came to our committee and said
whether we thought this funding
mechanism
was an appropriate mechanism okay and
I'm saying no it's not it's not
appropriate but I'm not ready to repeal
the whole thing just because the funding
mechanism doesn't work
I'm doing what I think is the
responsible thing to do is fix the
funding mechanism
now you can argue well you know that
that you know this is not going to see
the light of day but I would argue there
I will guarantee you what I know about
the Senate is that the Senate did is
committed to this affordability board
and the Senate it when that when the
budget comes back
the Senate will have the money now
whether in the committee a conference
the Senate is willing to go to the
carpet over this versus what other
issues may be differential between the
house and the Senate
you know that who knows nobody's got
nobody's got that crystal ball
but I would say to you that if by doing
this you now ended any discussion on the
house side about repealing it
and what you're doing instead is is
creating a funding mechanism the gel car
would approve
and keeping this this issue alive
because when it leaves here it's going
to the Senate
but how do we know it's going to pass
the Senate when Donna soucy didn't know
anything about it I mean I understand
that they don't have the majority but I
I'm pretty sure Donna Susie who's not
paying attention to all the bills that
are on the house side
um I I take I take you think she does
yeah I do okay well I mean I I I I would
you know you went on me being frank
I am surprised that Tom Sherman did not
tell her this issue was on the house
side that we had two of these bills I'm
shocked
I mean he's a former Senator he should
he knows full well how important this
this issue was to Donna
did she tell you it was important to her
this committee when you talk to her
Sherman oh you never talked to her okay
so you're you're getting her surprise
second hand okay
excuse me I trust what Tom Sherman says
he's an honorable man and I trust
whenever he tells me something like that
she was shocked yes okay
representative Gibbs
uh thank you
um just for clarity uh
this bill is not going to the finance
committee that is for sure
it would the only time the finance
committee will ever see this issue
is that if the Senate were to amend it
and come back and again it would come
back to us it wouldn't go back to
finance my assumption is by our passing
this
that the Senate will make sure this is
in their budget when they send the
budget back and that would go to finance
that is my assumption again my
assumption would be if they send it back
to finance that it'll be taken out
okay but that would be in the committee
conference and if for it to be taken out
that means the Senate got something else
that they care about
okay
if anyone doesn't in our caucus doesn't
have any more questions I'd like to meet
in the hall or what we can do we don't
have to do that you guys go ahead and
caucus and we'll make that decision when
we have the full commitment okay okay
all right and that and that will be
similar to the next one okay so the next
one is we don't need a subcommittee the
subcommittee we know we get it you know
I mean it makes sense to me
well you're on camera yeah
no no
all right the next one is uh five what's
the bill number
513.
okay so my understanding is there
there's two two pieces here the Salient
items in this build
um there is
the
uh RSA the 420b27 Roman numeral two
B
the reimbursement is equal to the
payment which would have otherwise been
made to the payer's preferred Pharmacy
provider
isn't that ironic okay
um so obviously to me that is a very
important sentence given that while we
heard in the public hearing was that
sometimes these these uh
cancer treatments and infusions are are
overbilled
and base because they're built under the
medical rather than the pharmaceutical
so to me that's the most important part
of this build the third Roman numeral
three uh where a patient may opt to do
this bagging brown white or whatever bag
you want to call it that um my
understanding is this is actually
current policy you know that this this
happens now so we don't really need to
pass that
so if that's offensive to people we can
take it out
and just and just not and go forward
with the bill without Roman numeral
three I can I can just I just want to
tell you why I think it's should be
taken out which is that right now and
Karen and we have another nurse here too
can can tell me over there I'm all wet
um right now
um
it's it right now the opt-in thing is
usually on a piece of paper in small
print that only Carrie would read
um because we know she reads the man
right and she's the smaller the print
the more suspicious he is but that's
what patients get
no they don't aren't aware that they're
that the uh if they opt into this that
they're going to have a cheaper
um way of paying and that's to the
hospital's advantage and it seems like
the way to do it would be to have the
default be to have a go to the patient
and then tell them well by the way you
can also get it here but here's the cost
differential
that's my take on that paragraph it's an
interesting concept to turn from an
opt-in to opt out or something but yeah
okay
no I I truly believe I agree with you
that the process is happening now in
terms of what's the roles the hospital
play is correct it's the right way and
it's really safe and sound and the idea
that you're getting it delivered and
having it it's it it seems a little
tacky to me they haven't had problems
with it yeah well so exactly it is it is
there so let me say is if it is already
current even if we don't pass that it
can still occur
because it's already something that's
happening so all we're doing is putting
in statue with something that's already
happening so I agree with you let's just
take it out
okay
so what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to get something that we all can agree
on you know because I you know how much
I love everything on the consent
calendar which so far is everything we
have so far
yes representative Gibbs thank you
um uh this is actually a question for
representative Burroughs um I understand
clearly your point about
um
the savings and expense
um but my question is about what we
heard during the hearing about the
concerns about safety in terms of having
the medication sent to the patients and
then carried by the patients to the
hospital or where or wherever
I guess I interpreted things differently
I don't know if um
I talked to somebody from the New
Hampshire Hospital Association is anyone
from there today
both of them are here yeah I mean and I
I don't I I'm not sure they would agree
with you that it's dangerous and um
um I mean they can tell me whether I'm
all wet but that's why what we did here
was that the service that delivers the
medication to the patient is often the
same service that delivers it to the
hospital exactly
and so and people have been receiving
their insulin forever in the you know
however they get their insulin they
weren't able to give us numbers that
were like below 99.5
that's they usually give it to them in a
packaging that can get it to the
hospital because remember the hospitals
get it the same way no
I'm sorry
um uh
okay maybe I I misunderstood
um but
what I heard
earlier testimony from
and I'm not sure whether it was a
Hospital Association but it was Health
Care Providers they were concerned about
the safety of the two-step process
because of the extra length of time
um in terms of of getting the medication
to the person who would administer it
which is different from insulin because
right and Insulin goes to the patient
the patient injections I think that's
only if the Good Humor man delivers it
but um I'm sorry I'm jumping around
um refrigerated yeah it is refrigerated
does the new New Hampshire Hospital
Association
but yeah here's what what I heard was it
goes to the patient and then the patient
takes the time to deliver it to the
hospital so that's the difference
between the Brown Bag during that step
that
that's the question that that one is
really yes we we would most most of us
would be very concerned if it was being
delivered to the to the patient at their
home and then they were responsible to
bring it in yes we all agree that that
is uh is is a little scary well I I
think that's okay that's the possibility
here so I my understanding and I and I
you know can't tell you we could
certainly open it up the whole reason
this concept exists in the first place
is going back to the problem of what we
want to fix in B which is that the
patient wanted the patient finds out for
some reason the patients got some skin
in the game when it came to that medical
billing and saw the outrageous price and
they said how do I get out of that well
they say is well if we deliver it to you
and you bring it in then you will make
sure that it is will be paid under the
pharmacy
uh provision
of their health insurance rather than
the medical which was doing the
overcharging in the first place
so that I'm saying is if we pass this
that I don't think there will be anybody
who will bother doing this Roman numeral
3 anymore because we've taken care of
why they would do it in the first place
which was the lower the costs for the
drug
would you mind if we asked the hospital
association their take on this not a
problem
yeah
good morning for the record my name is
Kathy Bazar with umberg Executive Vice
President New Hampshire Hospital
Association
Kathy Bazar with umberg from the
hospital Association and Paula minahan
Senior vice president state government
relations for the hospital Association
good morning
so just to clarify what um was being
asked about Brown bagging and white
bagging so just again to set the stage
so Brown bagging is the insurance
company's policy that requires a patient
to receive their medication at home
and they have to bring it to a hospital
or a provider for that hospital or
provider to administer it to them
the problem with the brown bagging is
that if the patient receives it either
late or the medication is wrong or it's
not stored properly that's the patient
safety concern that we have with brown
bagging with white bagging the
medication on behalf of a particular
patient gets sent to the hospital or
health care provider
but it doesn't come through the normal
chain of drug shipments it gets sent to
a shipping Department it may get sent to
another department especially if there's
no special tag on it or it may have a
patient name and they don't know who the
doctor is so sometimes it also gets lost
temperature not maintained and so forth
so that is why we have special concerns
about both Brown bagging and white
bagging there are certain circumstances
where white banking does make sense
depending on the particular patient and
the circumstance with that provider but
really what the concern that we have
with this bill is is the funding
mechanism that you've pointed out Mr
chairman
so the
concern here and I know that the sponsor
actually said this but we're not sure
that it's actually
written correctly in this amendment is
that he hopes that this whole process
for brown bagging gets put to an uh
Pharmacy benefit instead of a medical
benefit and as I mentioned to this
committee last week we are concerned
with a pharmacy benefit that the patient
is going to have more out-of-pocket
costs because typically Pharmacy
benefits have higher deductibles and
higher co-pays regardless of charges so
I also want to clarify with charges
hospitals Providers Insurance companies
have contracts regardless of what is
charged the reimbursement is what is
under contract that's not what they get
paid so let's be clear the payments are
negotiated between the provider
and the insurance company and the
patient also benefits from that
negotiated rate
so so your sounds like you you agree
with that's removed paragraph This Roman
numeral three and that that b uh again
only reaffirms what you think is already
happening
I don't understand what b means to be
honest
I think this bill is not written very
carefully it is not clear that this is
truly going to a pharmacy benefit I know
what the sponsor said but the the way
it's written is extremely unclear we
just don't think this bill is ready for
prime time and we think that this bill
should be itl right well I I obviously
you say I disagreed I know exactly what
the bill is saying when it says the
payers preferred Pharmacy provider
that's directly referral to what's on my
little health insurance card
and that is that negotiated rate between
the insurer and the provider
so theoretically we're just reiterating
which should already be true
so
representative um
where are you again what line I am well
if you're looking at numbers but
22 no excuse 20. 20. but that's why I
always do rsas because sometimes people
print them out but yes 20. um
so there's the reimbursement and then
there's the benefit and that's where I
think it is confusing
um
I I find this very confusing and as you
know we discuss you have a better way to
say it
the implications the unintended
consequences potential um
um the potential impact negative impact
um not not only to the patient but also
to the to the provider
um are are significant this is confusing
um and I again as Kathy indicated we do
not believe this bill is is written in a
way that we can certainly understand it
I've been doing this for a long time and
Kathy even longer so I I I'm struggling
with this as well I don't know if this
means I think this is rate setting um
and I you and I have talked about this
this is rate setting because you're
setting a rate that is not that is
outside the contracts between the
carriers and the providers because it is
setting a rate that is the provide the
hospital at least in the hospitals they
don't negotiate a pharmacy benefit per
se unless you own a specialty pharmacy
so it is all falls under the medical
benefit and again as Kathy indicated
this is a this is a private negotiation
between a carrier and a meniscus for our
in our in our members case hospitals so
I'm still very I'm struggling I really
am um with with how this would be
um administered and but this is I think
it's rate setting because it's you're
defaulting to a rate that had that falls
under the pharmacy benefit that is
set I guess between the PBM and the
insurer that may or may they may
actually own the PBM so that's the rate
that the hospitals would be required
under this to default to that's rate
setting
that's that's the the legislature would
be setting the rates by doing that in
our the way we read it so I think there
are a lot of potential unintended
consequences okay
I just want to thank you for saying it
was confusing because I had a headache
after reading it 20 times and I thought
that I just simply wasn't that bright
which it doesn't mean that isn't true
but I couldn't figure it out that I I
find it very confusing and you are very
bright so um yeah I I struggle with this
language I do
but I guess yeah so we have a we have a
replacement here who's a nurse yeah
from Goffstown uh District 29. and I'm a
nurse and I've been a nurse for many
years I do find this very confusing
um this bill and the big thing is is
what you're saying exactly with about
the brown bagging or white bagging I
think it has a lot of safety concerns
for the patient I think basically as we
know that the meal delivery sometimes
can be late you could have
um it placed somewhere say if you did
the white bagging it could be placed
somewhere and then it's not brought up
to the floor or brought to where it
needs to be and um and that's a big
problem and also I think also in regards
to this
this reimbursement and everything like
that I think is also very confusing I I
don't feel that this bill is ready for
prime time
okay
um thank you very much you're welcome so
uh the last thing when we talked about
this we had tasked the insurance
department with uh coming up because the
question was posed by the medical
society that this was confusing or also
whether that uh this the consumers would
be her uh the patients would be harmed
based upon co-pays and deductibles I
think is what it was the question that
was posed so is the department prepared
to uh tell us what they think about that
problem
and I guess add into it um is is this
sentence confusing for you or do you you
know how you would be able to enforce
this and do you consider it uh uh rate
setting
thank you
right I requested
okay so Alex why don't you
why don't you tell everybody who you are
um yeah just talk to the mic because we
have one person oh yeah I'm Alex valve
from the insurance examiner four from
the insurance department
and
um we were asked to take a look at the
amendment and effectively
um
do the work of uh producing a fiscal
note for that Amendment
um
and
um as pointed out in the memo that you
have
um they're basically three methods of
delivering specialty drugs
um the first one is the buy and Bill
method which is associated with the
highest costs
and health carriers in an effort to
control those high costs have developed
relationships with specialty pharmacies
and as you now I think understand there
are two ways that those um
clinician and Minister drugs get
delivered by specialty pharmacies either
directly to the clinic called White
bagging or through the patient called
Brown banging
um the most expensive again method is
buying Bill
and what section two of this bill
would do is basically
require the health carrier to reimburse
in the buy and Bill method so that's the
coverage requirement if you look at that
line
um
it says an HMO
shall not refuse to authorize approve or
pay for
clinician administered drugs given
certain conditions so it's a coverage
requirement
on the health carrier
so that's the benefit part of it and
then as a condition condition for that
coverage requirement
you have the most importantly of section
B which requires that it the
reimbursement be equal to
the what the reimbursement would have
been for white bagging arrangement
so it's sort of a compromise and we in
the sense that it requires the carriers
to cover buy and Bill
um but at the same time it provides that
that method won't be more expensive than
the current option of white bagging
so
um given that's what the bill does
um
our analysis is that it would lead to a
lowering of claims costs and therefore
would lead to
lower premiums
okay any questions from committee
members
representative Gibbs thank you uh
would your analysis of lower premiums
apply both to the original Bill and to
the amendment that was submitted by
chairman hunt
do I don't
the department Christopher sorry yeah
you got to put yes Chris the gallopolis
the commissioner of insurance department
the department had some concerns with
the language of the original bill and we
worked with the sponsor and other
interested people to to flesh all that
out and so our fiscal analysis was not
on the original bill which we would have
different testimony for but is on uh the
language of the bill here
um and I don't think it would be
impacted by I know there was some
conversation about whether or not we
take out as a paragraph to see uh the
final tariff I don't think
uh I don't think our analysis would be
changed about whether or not that came
out or not
representative spear
do hospitals
the expression I wouldn't have gotten
this
the reimbursement is equal to the
payment which would have otherwise been
made to the payer's preferred Pharmacy
provider correct so do the hospitals
know what that is
um they are claiming that it's confusing
oh that's right I got to write you're
claiming that sentence is confusing okay
they they feel a little a little fuzzy
about what that sentence means and
thank you I don't mean
I mean the amount of money
oh the amount of money yes so if I'm
gonna say all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
have the the I'm going to provide the uh
drugs
but I can only charge so much amount of
money do they not even know what that is
representative Spirit they'd have to
provide that information they wouldn't
know it today because this isn't the law
today and I think in large part this is
this is a solution to a very small part
of the Specialty Pharmacy solution I
think what the the number one solution
is for providers that are providing
these specialty drugs and the carriers
to enter into contracts just like they
do with everything else exactly and I've
seen you know I've been commissioned now
for three years and I've I've watched a
number of these uh
negotiations happen and that is by far
the most effective way where they can
balance all of the interest of all of
the parties and in those cases they
agree to some some kind of contractual
fee schedule between the two of them
um one of the wild cards there and for
those folks that don't agree to that you
know kind of carrot and stick you need a
mechanism for how you're going to deal
with it one of those mechanisms is brown
bagging and white bagging then what we
hear is well for some of this specialty
cancer treatment we don't know what the
concoction is or we don't know the
volume until that morning
we heard that over over the this last
year and so this bill deals with that
one kind of the last minute we need to
change the dosage we need to change the
volume
here we go guys we're going to now it's
not on the fee schedule or you opted not
to have a contracted fee schedule here's
the solution you can provide it patient
number one that's our goal for everyone
and here's the the reimbursement amount
I think this is a this I've testified
now a second time on this bill I think
this is a wonderful solution to the
problems have been outlined as it
relates to Brown Value white bagging But
ultimately continues to provide the
incentive for the providers and the
carriers to negotiate all of this
um and I think I think if we pass this
we're going to continue to do that
representative Gibbs thank you uh would
you believe that not when a procedure is
a medical procedure is performed neither
the doctors nor the nurses nor the
technicians ever know what the actual
cost to the patient is going to be and I
know this because I almost always ask
and they almost always say
the billing department will tell you
when they've talked to the insurance
company and figured it out
I would believe I agree
he very much agrees
okay any other
questions to the committee members okay
team none
oh I'm sorry that some providers know
not only the costs but exactly what
conditions those particular medications
need to be kept under in order for them
to be able to be administered safely
know the cost yes and I I believe I
believe you but I have never run into
one in my entire life literally never I
wish I had
okay
all right thank you very much
um so uh this this is the same situation
you guys go ahead and and caucus and see
where you guys are with this
um I I would say that you know us
Republicans uniformly we want to pass
both these bills and so you just you
know if you if if you want me to take
this paragraph out I just need to know
sooner yeah I just need to know sooner
or later to figure out what to do sure
great go ahead
perfect and we Republicans will caucus
too okay
I think everybody
thank you
okay we will open up the exact session
and uh
what we'll do is we'll take up the two
bills uh the first one house bill 130
and uh representative Burroughs second
by representative hunt moves to retain
representative Burroughs is recognized
to speak to her motion
okay
um we would like to retain
um HP 130 to enable the um the pharmacy
Advisory Board to look for other options
for funding and to not disband the work
that they've been doing
the span the work they're doing disband
yeah no obviously nobody was talking
about the spanning okay well I just
added that okay
okay
so okay so uh the motion is to retain is
there any questions on the motion
see none the I will urge everyone to
vote to retain
and the clerk would call the roll
representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic
he's out uh Terry
oh
yeah yeah
well that's all right we don't need them
sorry we're retaining
okay uh Cole
Porcelli yes Thaxton
Walsh yes Burrows
yes Herbert
Clark yes
lonza yes Vincent yes collabro yes
philio yes Gibbs yes spear yes
seabird
yes
and representative hunt yes
it's 17. okay 17 to zero all right
uh next is uh
I should know the bills by the number by
now 513 513
representative Burroughs second by
representative hunt moves to retain
representative Burroughs is recognized
to speak to her motion
thank you yes yes we would like to
retain HB 513 we'd like the opportunity
to
um make the language of the bill clearer
and more understandable
and we recognize the benefits of both
Brown bagging and white bagging and
we're hoping to keep costs down for the
consumer
evidently not the cost of Premium
okay
all right any other discussion on the
motion to retain
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
all right representative Ammon yes
Osborne
is he back nope
um
Cole yes Porcelli yes Paxton yes Walsh
yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes lonza yes Vincent
yes
collabro
philio yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Siebert
yeah
and chairman hunt yes
17. okay
Lisa post is here all right one more
action
um and that is Lisa is here Lisa oh okay
post
okay so the vote was 18. okay the Last
Action is
um the house bill
584 uh there has some new information
has come available and so uh We've uh we
would like to reconsider our action
where we passed it but
almost University I think there was one
person who voted against it and
well you would you like this part but uh
so anyway so the motion uh is to
reconsider our action on House Bill 584
the motion being made by representative
Ammon
second by representative hunt I think I
need to get
I don't think you really would have them
so this is the article 12 the UCC bill
and we actually passed the main UCC Bill
last year but this was a a patchwork of
little things that have come up uh but
then it turns out that there was a a
little bit of a poison pill in there and
so we want to remove that poison pill to
uh so that we have a nice clean UCC
statute and I just lost my clerk
representative Ammon explain that
actually we can vote on it because we
could we don't need to have a roll call
vote I can we can do that by far I'll
speak to it once whenever it's okay so
all those in favor reconsideration
please say aye those opposed
okay almost your names all right so now
representative you can go ahead and
speak to your motion right so I passed
around two pieces of paper one is
amendment to 584 and
it strikes a section in the original
bill
okay I passed them that way maybe
they're right here is this it this this
is them
you can't see actually I need one
so there's there's two pieces of paper
one is uh right an amendment and the
other is uh the definition of money
okay
everybody gets it
on TV too
okay so okay I think everyone's got the
GPS everybody's got it and
uh representative Anderson recognized to
speak to his motion all right so uh UCC
12 there's been some controversy in the
news recently about uh UCC article 12
the governor of South Dakota just vetoed
their entire bill
and it's based on uh many misconceptions
about what UCC 12 does
we passed that we passed a very near
final draft of UCC 12 last term last
year actually
and so 584 is just a cleanup bill it's
just to uh make a few minor changes
mostly minor changes to the final draft
that the uniform law commission produced
and what we passed last year so 584 is
it's a housekeeping Bill like in the
truest sense
but they added one definition uh that to
the definition of money and if there's a
second piece of paper here the language
in bold
is going to be would be added by 584 to
our statute the language that is not in
bold is already in statute
and so the amendment is to just strike
this out leave it leave current statute
uh the definite definition of money
leave it as is and we'll consider adding
this separately This this term so the
language that would be added unless we
Act is the term includes a monetary unit
of account established by an
intergovernmental organization or
pursuant to an agreement between two or
more countries and
the use for this would be a central bank
digital currency an intergovernmental
organization could be the IMF or some
you know some Global organization uh
pursuant to an agreement between two or
more countries we've heard that China
and Russia and potentially Iran might be
working on their own banking system so
that would fall under this definition we
want to be careful about uh introducing
this into our statute without a uh you
know a reasoned uh discussion about it
so when the bill moves to the Senate we
could have it then or we can we have one
retained bill that is meant to address
Central Bank digital currencies we
retain that one here in this committee
so that might be a vehicle to use to
sort of get this right but
um so I would ask everyone to just
support this amendment and make this the
committee Amendment and then we can put
put the bill back on consent so what's
my request
okay any discussion on the motion yes
representative spear not for nothing
no way do I want this this to be
attached to that Central Bank currency
thing
so you do right you would you agree with
getting Central Bank out of this bill
right
I would do it the way we want to do it
here that was the right answer
okay
okay so representative Ammon second by
representative hunt moves uh
ought to pass on amendment number
right
okay yeah
just a second
okay yes representative Herbert
I just wanted to point out that the last
last session I spoke against the
community particles and the vote I think
was 150 to 100
so there is
uh This is Not By Any Means
a unanimous effort
because there are 150 votes there were
with me
and I still am very much against
it could you put your sound on yeah I'm
sorry your microphone yeah I'm sorry I
didn't even notice
pull it close to you
so my my opposition is uh comprehensive
in other words I reject
what we passed in the last session
and I I therefore reject
anything that is associated with uh and
and has the capability of disrupting
our Constitution and and the
Congressional Monopoly over the uh money
supply
right in the Constitution and it's there
for a reason
a monetary Sovereign Nation is one
nation and has one currency
and there's a reason for that you can't
control the money supply if there is a
private currency that has been
recognized as a substitute for our
dollar and that is what all of this is
about
and so I I reject the concept and I'm I
understand a lot of people are very
interested in cryptocurrencies and and
the ecology that's there and uh it's a
nice shiny Bible and it's it's code and
it's like cool and that's sexy now but
currency is a is a thing that goes back
500 600 years or more and has withstood
a lot of uh uh ups and downs
so I'm not going to vote to
compromise the money supply and the
Monopoly of Congress that's in the
Constitution and that's what I'm being
asked to do I'm not going to do it so it
sounds like to me that you agree with
this amendment because you think there
should only be one currency for the
United States government even though you
might vote against the bill
in general but you really do support
this amendment because you don't like
the idea of any government entity having
their own digital currency what this is
all about it's a private currency that
is what is wanted and this is a
government one
do you think it's a good idea that the
gov the federal government have its own
digital currency
and what's the dollar is that the dollar
no
do you think it'd be okay for them to
create a new one but it is based on the
dollar it is still based on the dollar
you think so it is if you read the
Federal Reserve notes it is still based
on the dollar it is not a separate
currency it's a separate instantiation
of the dollar gotcha okay private
currency and it will be outside the
banking it is not outside the banking
system and it is not a private currency
okay representative spear I mean
Representative Vincent thank you
representative thank you uh Mr chairman
um I would have to agree to some point
uh and maybe I'm wrong but this is just
my comment that
to purchase this and correct me if I'm
wrong
this is an online type of deal correct
to purchase this currency would be
online can I just clarification here
sure please so UCC article 12 deals with
digital assets so they call them
controllable electronic records it
encompasses a ton of different things so
it could be any any digital token that
you can trade online it can include
cryptocurrency but it conclude it can
include a whole bunch of other things
right um so it's it's a very broad
category but it has to do with value
that's represented by a digital token
and these are becoming widespread in
lots of different use cases
um you know Chuck E cheese issues its
own money but it's not a threat to the
US dollar right right so you know a
digital token can be something simple
like a token to use to operate a system
online like a video game system my
comment is not against it it's just that
um I think when you're talking about
digital currency it's worldwide
so it's not just to the United States
that's what my comment was it goes
wherever the internet goes that's
correct yeah in that case it's true yes
representative
just as a point of clarification we're
discussing right now whether the
amendment to ought to pass because
already last week
ought to pass the underlying Bill
correct and the sole question here is
whether we agree that the underlying
bill should not recognize digital
currencies is that the question before
us right now
government digital currency yes thank
you yes government digit so really all
we should be debating right now is this
underlying amount that is true thank you
that is true appreciate it okay is the
question clear uh ought to pass on the
amendment the clerk will call the roll
Osborne
petusic yes yes Terry yes
post yes call yes
pacelli yes baxton
Burroughs
whoops Walsh sorry yes
Burrows yes Herbert
absolutely not
clerk yes
Lanza yes
Vincent yes collabro yes
Helio yes Gibbs yes spear yes Siebert
chairman hunt yes yes
all right motion carries representative
Ammon second by representative patusek
moves ought to pass as amended is there
any discussion on the question
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
when she's ready
so what
we did we did the reconsideration by
Voice vote that was adopted the
amendment so now the pending motion is
ought to pass as amended
right but
what's this motion so this motion is now
the uh to pass as amended okay
oh boy now I'm gonna have to get another
one but that's okay
well this is this yes this was a session
right
so this is the second one here right
here okay all right got it and then
um
this is ought to pass as amended I got
it okay so this one is uh Ammon and
petusic yeah
okay
sorry
all right representative Ammon yes
Osborne
petusic yes Terry yes yes post yes call
yes Porcelli yes Paxton
Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert
absolutely not
Clark yes
lonza yes
Vincent yes collabro yes phillio yes
Gibbs yes spear yes steamer
rep uh chairman hunt yes okay all those
in favor replacing uh house bills
84 on the consent Calendar please say
aye
those opposed
no no you have to be unanimous to put it
on the consent calendar you really want
this on the regular calendar
going to take another shot at it yep
all right we've had it on consent last
week
it was already on consent
I'm against the entire concept
you're going to get up and make a speech
and tell everybody to to
vote down this bill
that's what you want to do
okay we will leave it on the regular
calendar and this will be the only
Commerce bill on the regular calendar
with that we were out of exact session
wow
uh Chris
yeah how short is it supposed to be sure
sure
so that's the motion
I was not in favor of the old version
it's your recommendation would be
keyboard